alors bon soir c'est vraiment un
privilège pour moi ce soir d'être avec
vous tous parce que bon comme thème
comme titre j'ai choisi aventure et sa
vie parce que j'ai vraiment l'impression
que ma vie c'est une belle aventure j'ai
pas seulement l'impression je la vis
vraiment comme une belle aventure
puis pour moi aventure et sa vie c'est
oser vivre sa vie alors ça commence je
me souviens quand ça a commencé en ayant
fait un recul c'est que tout jeune je me
souviens que mes parents ils m'ont donné
tout de suite le plus bel héritage qu'on
peut donner à ses enfants
non non n'est ce pas une ont donné le
plus bel héritage c'est qu'ils m'ont
fait confiance dans la vie et puis
d'aussi loin que je me rappelle j'étais
tout petit c'est cette confiance en moi
cette confiance qu'ils m'ont donné que
j'ai dans la vie qui a été mon
engagement finalement pour arriver à
vivre au jour le jour
puis comme disait richard c'est certain
qu'avec cette confiance qu'ils m'ont
accordée
ils m'ont donné la foi aussi la foi de
nos ancêtres mais c'est une fois qui
chez moi et les présents alors avec la
confiance qu'ils m'ont donné j'étais une
petite fille timide la cinquième d'une
famille de six enfants
alors tous les grands frères des grandes
soeurs des grandes cuisines des grands
cousins
alors finalement toi tu étais là tout
petit mais quand même vu que la
confiance était là j'ai toujours osé
aller un petit peu plus loin que ma
timidité et puis ce qui m'a vraiment
aidé puis ce qui est ce que j'essaie de
donner à mes enfants cette confiance
mais ce que j'essaie de leur donner
aussi comment ces merveilleux d'aidé
parce que pour arriver aventure et sa
vie sur ses bouteilles ou sais c'est
qu'il faut ce qu'on ait rossi puis pour
apprendre à se connaître avec nos
faiblesses nos forces nous dont total un
bain il faut si on donne on apprend tout
ça scusez
merci alors j'ai réalisé que en donnant
on apprend vraiment à se connaître on
apprend vraiment qui on est puis pour
rose et b pour savoir qui on est faut
connaître nos faiblesses faut connaître
nos forces
puis en vivant simplement en disant oui
à tout ça j'ai réalisé que nos
faiblesses souvent sont transformés en
en force
parce que en étant conscients de nos
faiblesses on ose mais on ose
humainement je dirais on ose humblement
alors tout petit encore une fois quel
plaisir c'était pour moi quand les
jambes
les voisins me faisait confiance pour
promener leur petit enfant dans les
carros dans les poussières j'arrêtais
tout on aurait dit que je suis tombé
dans une potion magique qui était celle
de l'amour des enfants parce que je
pouvais arrêter tous les jeux pour
promener les enfants
mais ce plaisir c'était pas que je
donnais mais les enfants me donner de la
joie aller promener parce qu'ils étaient
heureux de se faire promener mais moi
quel bonheur aussi de donner mon temps
de donner la petite ford enfants de 7 8
ans pour promener les enfants alors
encore là ça a été des étapes
primordiales pour moi parce que donner
c'est l'avis donné c'est oser vivre
alors ça m'a toujours véhiculé mais en
arrière c'était pas présent conscient
mais je réalisais au fur et à mesure que
c'était a donné que j'étais heureuse
et puis que les gens autour de moi
étaient heureux alors encore lola
confiance augmenté et le bonheur
augmenté alors c'est comme ça qu'un jour
j'ai fait un cours de physiothérapie
j'étais dans le premier groupe parce que
c'est des enfants qui m'ont amené à
faire ce cours là mais encore là c'était
pour aller plus loin dans l'amour
c'était pour aller plus loin dans la
vraie vie
puis finalement si tu donnes tu te
connaît alors tu peux entrer en relation
pis pour moi c'est sûr que je reviens à
la fois si on veut parce que le bon dieu
pour moi c'est le plus grand
personnage de relations puisqu'il nous
d'y entrer en relation et aimez vous
alors c'est vraiment ce que j'ai appris
avec ma confiance avec la connaissance
de qui j'étais que finalement c'est
merveilleux les rencontres c'est
merveilleux d'être vraiment en relation
tu parle à quelqu'un bongo son prénom
mais pour moi le prénom c'est ce qui
compte dans la vie
puis même je vous dirais ya des gens qui
sont chez moi depuis plusieurs années
pour aider
puis on m'a donné si on dit le nom
famille de la personne agit peut-être je
devrais la connaître mais l'eau si on
s'arrête seulement mon prénom je la
connais vraiment bien puis ce soir comme
les enfants ils vont parler des prénoms
mais moi je veux me souvenir aussi par
les prénoms sauf blues qui était une
personne spéciale
alors on va se souvenir aussi c'est un
peu comme son prénom alors entrer en
relation c'est extraordinaire
puis entrer en relation avec des
personnes en toute simplicité sans
jalousie sans méchants c'est simplement
on ne le goût de partager
alors ça nous amène à une fraternité ça
nous amène à l'entrée ça nous amène à
être vraiment comme une grande famille
puis je dire chez nous on arrive chez
nous on fait partie de la famille
ça peut être pour le moment pour une
fois pour deux fois on peut répéter mais
pour les enfants il ya personne de
dangereux
tout le monde est bienvenu quand
quelqu'un nouveaux arrivent chez nous si
bon et l ami arrive parfois moi je le
connais à peine mais les enfants
accueillent comme un ami accueille comme
un membre de la famille alors encore
l'eau s'intensifie notre fraternité 5
ans fille notre amour entre nous parce
qu'il ya beaucoup d'amour s'il ya de la
confiance a lancé pour moi ma devise
c'est un peu le devoir de l'imprévoyance
parce que le devoir de l'imprévoyance
sais que tu mets les habitudes de côté
parce que les habitudes ont freiné nos
élans les habitudes vont nous empêcher
d'être spontané d'aller spontanément
donner un sourire à quelqu'un ou donner
un coup de pouce à quelqu'un ou d'ouvrir
sa porte à quelqu'un parce que dans nos
habitudes dont le fait port puis
habitées
mambé on aimerait ça avoir une belle
table tout bien garni et des petits mais
si on n'a pas d'habitude on est toujours
prêt toujours prêt à dire oui mais pour
moi le oui c'est un organe
c'est un engagement c'est c'est un
contrat finalement si depuis j'ai appris
à mes enfants puis je le répète aussi si
on a dit oui à quelqu'un pour quelque
chose note swiss ça vaut un contrat
signé en dix étapes en dix exemplaires
parce que c'est notre fidélité à notre
oui à notre conscience et on est heureux
même s'ils se présentent quelque chose
d'autres mains on a dit oui c'est sûr
encore une fois ma foi mamine facilement
parce que pour moi le chemin le plus
facile c'est le chemin de l'avant donc
c'est le chemin où on ne peut pas
d'habitude où tout ça entre en jeu mais
c'est peut-être le plus difficile à
trouver mais j'ai trouvé le moyen
d'avancer mieux dans ce chemin là c'est
en adoptant mes enfants parce que ils
sont d'une spontanéité
puis ils sont très fidèles à leur ouïe
pourtant ils sont limités
intellectuellement mais quand ils disent
oui à quelqu'un c'est vraiment un oui et
puis ils ont quand tu n'as pas
d'habitude qui t'empêche qui te ferait
finalement c'est le coeur qui agit
toujours en premier et puis pour moi la
vraie intelligence ça se voit ça se
commune et par notre relation envers les
autres
si on nous présente quelqu'un et on a de
la misère à saluer on a de la misère on
est tout inquiet puis on cherche quelque
chose
ben c'est pas la vraie intelligence du
coeur
christian bobin un théologien français
nous dit que un grand scientifique et
qui a de la misère dans ses relations
c'est con un squelette avec un habit de
soi j'aime beaucoup sa comparaison parce
que c'est vrai c'est le coeur qui parle
avant toute autre chose puis avec le
coeur
ben finalement on est toujours prêt à
donner on est toujours prêt à aller de
l'avant
alors c'est nos relations aussi qu'ils
sont augmentés puis si on veut avancer
avec tout ce bagage l'a finalement on
s'aventure vraiment on n'est pas inquiet
de l'avenir
on y va au temps présent dans le fur et
à mesure qu'ils ont peut accueillir les
événements souvent l'événement qui est
très ce qui est une épreuve qui est un
obstacle mais si on lui laisse le temps
de retomber si on veut retomber la
poussière on s'aperçoit que l'événement
nous amener beaucoup plus loin qu'on
sera les sons étaient restées là
négative face à l'événement alors
l'événement faut attendre finalement
faut être patient puis voir ce qu'ils
ont à nous dire
un peu comme pour moi niaise et c'est
important dans la vie puis je trouve que
les enfants maintenant on n'y as pas
assez parce que pour moi ni avis c'est
pas perdre du temps c'est laisser notre
imagination finalement aller puis un
moment donné l'imagination nous nous
donne un projet nous apporte une
surprise nous apporte un éclairage sur
quelque chose qu'on avait pas ou on fait
quelque chose on y est mais en lisant ou
si on a découvert la belle nature
on a découvert un paquet chose alors
pour moi c'est important manic les
enfants et pas d'activité puis qu'ils
aillent chacun long selon leurs goûts
bon si on goûte simplement d'écouter de
la musique ou deux percées ou d'aller se
promener mais niazi mais d'une façon
constructive pour moi ça c'est
primordial
puis si on n'a pas des on est trop
encore une fois les habitudes mais si on
est tout près dans un classement
d'habitude mais finalement on se donne
plus le tas de niaiser on se donne plus
le temps de penser puis pour moi le la
pensée ça me mène toujours à plus
d'amour alors penser autrement ou parlée
autrement je pense que c'est vivre en
amour alors aventure et sa vie c'est
vraiment oser vivre mais dans le moment
présent
et puis trouver sa passion mais avec les
éléments comme je vous disais avec la
confiance en soi avec le les relations
qu'ils deviennent faciles
avec notre wiki est un engagement qui
est une fidélité
mais on trouve vraiment notre passion
puis on va au delà de ce qu'on aurait
planifié c'est moi j'avais planifié bon
de travailler avec les enfants et tout
ça j'aurais jamais planifié de faire des
repas propre par jour pour une trentaine
de personnes
j'aurais marqué tout ça que je vous
dirais que j'aime ça pour moi c'est un
vrai miracle demi à faire à manger gras
avec tout ce monde là mais c'est s'est
fait tellement c'est bon pour les
enfants pour les personnes que j'aime
paysans bus ça devient c'est vraiment
une vacance continuelle parce que je
suis toujours dans ma passion finalement
puis quand encore une fois il ya des
événements malheureux où il ya des
obstacles
je pense que les obstacles sont là pour
permettre aux passionnés d'aller encore
plus loin
qui sait peut-être ça qui a fait que
maintenant vous n'avez certains
obstacles dans le sens que bonds à la
maison c'est sûr j'ai des gens qui
viennent aider certains rémunéré
certains bénévoles mais c'est pas la
quantité mais c'est la qualité puis un
moment donné bon suite au tremblement
terre en haïti la folie d'aller aider
nous emmener en haïti mais j'avais une
personne vraiment à temps complet depuis
18 ans mais finalement la folie
l'emmener là bord mais finalement le bon
dieu s'occupe du projet et puis si je
m'étais arrêté à penser mais qu'est ce
qu'on va faire qu'est-ce qui va arriver
c'est pas de ne pas penser d'être
téméraire mais je pense que ça rejoint
mon devoir de l'imprévoyance parce que
si on fait notre devoir
faut pas se préoccuper de l'imprévoyance
faux dans notre amour faut être prudent
on n'est jamais assez imprudents en
amour
souvent on cesse pas aimer comme on
devrait parce que on s'imagine toutes
sortes de choses on commence à penser
est ce que c'est vrai est ce que ces
pauvres est fait ce qui va arriver
puis si je donne trop d'amour à un
enfant ici et si et ça alors finalement
on n'avance pas mais dans le devoir
blain prévoyance c'est sûr qu'on fait de
la place au bon dieu mais il est là pour
ça mais pour moi c'est
c'est un devoir parce qu'il ya toujours
quelque chose de très positif qui arrive
c'est vraiment la vraie vie parce que
c'est toujours un défi qui nous amène
plus loin mais qui nous fait grandir le
coeur tout simplement
puis encore une fois pour moi aventure
et s'habille oser vivre sa vie c'est
aussi dire oui à des moments de silence
dire oui pas de moments silence dire oui
au silence finalement dire oui aux
semences paulo
mais ce qui se passe à l'intérieur de
moi puis comment je peux aller plus loin
avec ça c'est dire oui à l'imprévu à
toutes les choses les événements plus ou
moins malheureux qui arrive vous heureux
mais dire oui à tout ça c'est aussi dire
oui à la rencontre mais à la rencontre
sans jugement sans jalousie puis soit on
rencontre quelqu'un puis là on se
faisait ça mais je réalise que si c'est
toujours positif quand on rencontre
quelqu'un qu'on trouve toujours
l'élément positif de la personne mais
finalement ça devient toujours des
rencontres tellement grande somme je
vous le sommet je le fais pas toujours
un il ya pas si longtemps quelqu'un
vient la maison passer quelques jours
pour voir bon si elle aimerait ça
partager un peu la vie chez nous avec
les enfants aidés tout ça mais je vous
dirais que la première journée bon c'est
formidable parce que ça l'a fait à la
maison fait tu es quelqu'un mais il y
avait eu des petites choses serait quand
même assez exigeant quand les gens
arrivent il faut qu'ils rendant dans les
consignes de la famille pour pas des
balances et les enfants alors je dis
simplement mais je le dis quand même
puis le lendemain gpec trou parlé un
petit peu à la personne responsable chez
dc clos l'homme je vous dirais que les
emplois sans qu'on leur ai parlé on
sentit tout ce climat là que finalement
j'avais semé un jeu demander pardon hein
parce que après ça j'ai réalisé comment
la personne était malheureuse mais
j'étais pas mal
responsable de tout ça là j'ai rappelé
mon monde et deux personnes que j'avais
ma ligne ici puis finalement ça s'est
rétabli ça a été extraordinaire là mais
on a toujours avancé dans sa mais j'ai
réalisé comment c'était important
c'était juste des choses ce terrier
d'extraordinaire alors j'ai dit c'est
vraiment important club ont pu mes
enfants ils sont vraiment contagieux à
tous ceux ils vont pas l'expliquer par
des mots mais sans cela tout ce qu'ils
vivent et le moindre sentiment qu'on
peut avoir ou sentiment heureux ils vont
le sentir
mais je vous dirais que c'est la
première fois que ça m'arrive ici en
pleine phase là si peu mais finalement
ça s'est bien terminé parce que bon on
ne réagit vite puis la personne va
emmener avec nous à plein temps mais l
eau tout vécu son allant jusqu'à un
certain point si on regarde l'événement
c'est très positif parce que nous ça
nous a fait prendre conscience
encore une façon plus grande les plus
tangibles commencé important notre
accueil comment c'est important la
relation qui commence importants comme
je vous dis de trouve toujours trouver
quelque chose de positif à la personne
qu'on rencontre ça peut être un sans
abri ça peut être un premier mini ça
peut être n'importe qui mais souvent on
a des jugements puis on commence à
parler entre nous une petite affaire peu
nos petites affable ça devient tellement
gros puis moi dans le fond mes enfants
et c'est pas des enfants rois mais c'est
des enfants à être que je vous dirais
comme je vous dis ils ont senti tout son
sens qu'on dise aux rixes tout le monde
on était très poli très respectueux
alors c'est vraiment de toujours trouver
dans nos relations
dire oui à nos relations alors si j'ai
dit oui j'ai pas le droit de faire ce
que j'avais fait alors c'est ça nous
permet d'aller plus loin encore dans la
vie parce qu'à vente sur et sa vie c'est
toujours plein de défis alors si on dit
oui au défi mais finalement on va
toujours être plus grand c'est un moment
donné quand j'ai adopté mon premier
enfant
mes parents bon bien confiance meilhon
est inactif et c'est pour la vie mais il
avait confiance que c'était vraiment
la vie mais ils ont cru bon de me le
dire ils ont eu raison parce que puis un
moment donné pourquoi un puis deux puis
bon mais jamais j'aurais pu j'aurais pu
évaluer dire comment tu peux aimer bon
j'ai adopté jusqu'à 37 enfants comment
tu peux aimer 37 enfants au lieu d'en
nommer un ou deux ou trois comme un
petit peu mais je vous dirais que
l'amour fraternel moi je fais pas le
donner
puis je trouve ça extraordinaire l'amour
fraternel
puis comme je vous dis la maison est
ouverte alors les amis qui viennent
c'est de l'amour maternel de l'amour
fraternel qui donne d'amour comme des
ongles détendre alors c'est mes enfants
y vivent dans un climat d'amour
privilégiées alors c'est pour moi ça me
continue ma vie est pas fini bon c'est
encore jeune 69 ans et demi mais il ya
encore plein de projets mais pour moi
c'est ça oser vivre avec toutes ces oui
puis avec ceux de voir d'imprévoyance
dans la foi naturellement mais aimer et
se laisser aimer surtout on a beaucoup
de difficulté à se laisser aimer mais
encore là la confiance en soi les
relations l'engagement c'est primordial
dans la vie
puis une fidélité à nos engagements
parce qu'on peut s'engager mais sans
être fidèle alors pour moi si c'est
l'amour qui est au coeur de tout ça on
ne peut pas être infidèle peu moins
faire que l'autre ou plus plus - talent
mais tout le monde finalement on était
go to nom est unique on a tous quelque
chose à apporter à l'autre puis pour moi
c'est ça avant de se ré sa vie s'est
trouvée tout ça puis oser vivre sa vie à
cent pour cent
merci beaucoup